[Música]
momento de hablar de salud en directo
América de France 24 por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañera mar
Romero salamar bienvenida Muchas gracias
Valentina vamos a empezar hablando de la
salud de las mujeres aparece que hay un
vínculo entre estas terapias hormonales
para la menopausia y ciertos tipos de
demencia Así es son unos datos que se
publicaron ayer por el diario bmg y el
diario británico de salud bien y es un
estudio que recoge además miles de datos
estadísticos de Dinamarca son 6.000
60.000 Perdón mujeres en total los datos
que han recogido Entonces es un estudio
bastante sólido en este sentido y
básicamente lo que concluye es que las
mujeres que han tomado o tomaron
medicamentos de terapia hormonal para
aliviar los síntomas de la menopausia
algo que es pues relativamente común por
ejemplo el estrógeno la progestina
tuvieron luego más casos de demencias
entre ellas el alzheimer en total 24%
más de riesgo Aquí vemos el gráfico no
vemos la primera puntos las personas que
no usaron y vemos además como a medida
que aumentan los años de uso de este
tipo de medicamentos se va desplazando
esta barra que nos indica el riesgo de
haber desarrollado demencias hasta el
74% en el caso de las mujeres que lo
tomaron por más de 12 años en este
sentido no es el primer estudio que se
hace y no todos además han arrojado los
mismos datos Así que no es tan
concluyente por ejemplo durante mucho
tiempo se pensó que aumentaban el riesgo
de demencia este tipo de medicamentos si
se prescribían muy tarde digamos Más
allá de los 65 años cuando las mujeres
ya llevaban bastantes años de menopausia
pero que no aumentaba si se prescribía
Pues justo en el momento de que
aparecieran los síntomas de esta
menopausia sin embargo este estudio por
ejemplo algo de lo nuevo que arroja Es
que esto no tendría por qué ser así la
mitad de las mujeres cuyos datos se
recogen aquí en la publicación empezaron
a tomar los medicamentos antes de los 53
años entonces parecería que No
necesariamente hay Esa diferencia de
edad
veremos si realmente Se confirma o no
Porque como decíamos hay muchos datos y
no todos van en la misma dirección y sin
duda una información que puede resultar
inquietante para millones de mujeres por
supuesto que puede explicar mar este
vínculo entre la terapia hormonal y la
demencia Pues aquí está todavía la gran
incógnita que dejan este tipo de
investigaciones sabemos que hay un
vínculo sabemos que hay una relación
entre ambos pero no sabemos por qué y de
hecho los mismos autores del estudio en
sus conclusiones muestran no recuerdan
que sus datos lo que hacen sobre todo es
justificar más investigación para
determinar si esto es hallazgos
representan un efecto real de estas
terapias hormonales es decir si hay una
causalidad si la terapia hormonal
provoca demencia o si más bien reflejan
una predisposición subyacente de las
mujeres que necesitan este tratamiento
por ejemplo a veces unos síntomas de
menopausia puede ser problemas de
memoria no esto también puede ser algo
que va de la mano con síntomas de
demencia temprana
ahí es uno de los vínculos que existe
otro ejemplo que puede ser por ejemplo
la menopausia también provocaba
problemas para dormir sabemos que dormir
mal también tiene efectos en
enfermedades neurológicas no En ese
sentido podría ser que las mujeres que
tienen más síntomas de menopausia tanto
se le recetan estos tratamientos
hormonales como también aumentan el
riesgo de desarrollar demencia por esos
problemas de sueño estamos poniendo
algunos ejemplos No aquí que no tienen
por qué ser los únicos y por eso en ese
sentido también hay voces que defienden
que en este momento estos resultados no
deberían cambiar la práctica clínica de
recetar estos medicamentos para los
síntomas de la menopausia mientras que
hay otras que defienden que más bien
primero se intente para el manejo de
estos síntomas Buscar cambios de hábito
cambias de cambios de vida cosas que
mejoren en este sentido antes de usar la
medicación Pero bueno la conclusión
Clara es que se necesita más
investigación en la salud de las mujeres
y de todas las personas que toman este
tipo de medicamentos por ejemplo también
se usa terapia hormonal para las mujeres
trans entonces también son muchas
poblaciones las que pueden estar
afectadas y debemos investigar más sin
duda Esta es la conclusión mar porque
pues puede generar una alarma bastante
grande Sí definitivamente y por eso al
final en los desconocimientos Aunque
nacen estos miedos y cuando tenemos
informaciones cuando podemos hacer algo
al respecto Así que este es el llamado
totalmente mar pasamos a hablar de gripe
aviar tema diametralmente diferente han
identificado uno de los motivos por los
cuales esta enfermedad no se contagia
tan fácilmente a los humanos Sí es en
ese sentido es una buena noticia
realmente es una investigación que se
publicó en nature que la hizo la
universidad de Glasgow y lo que hicieron
es encontrar un gen en los humanos que
nos hace resistentes a varios virus de
esta gripe había recordemos que hay
varios virus y dentro de estos virus hay
varias cepas que pueden provocar esta
esta enfermedad este Gen recibe el
nombre de btn3 A3 que para facilitarnos
la vida apodaron como fuerza ave y es
responsable de la respuesta inmune que
se expresa tracto respiratorio Alto Como
por ejemplo la nariz no como el tracto
respiratorio Bajo como en los pulmones y
parece que evolucionó ya con nosotros
desde los primates y lo que hace es
evitar que el virus se replique esto es
muy importante porque en estos
monitoreos de posibles futuras pandemias
la gripe aviar tiene es una de las
enfermedades que tiene más papeletas
digamos de poder ser una de los orígenes
de una próxima crisis sanitaria Aquí
vemos un análisis que hacía Gustavo del
Real del csic de España que lo recoge
Science media Center y que dice eso no
que el virus que causa gripe aviar son
de los candidatos con más probabilidades
de provocarnos problemas graves en el
futuro no y de hecho con el último brote
entre de gripe aviar entre aves que ha
asolado el mundo de hecho casos y casos
en todo el mundo vimos que habían hasta
llegado a contagiar a mamíferos Entonces
en ese caso estaba en un paso más cerca
a nosotros y eso había generado mucha
preocupación esta investigación sirve un
poco pues para poner algo de Claridad en
estas preocupaciones bueno y sin embargo
este Gen del que usted está hablando en
principio no nos protege de todos los
virus de la gripe aviar no todo podían
ser buenas noticias lamentablemente no
los bloquea a todos Hay algunos que
escapan de la inhibición por ejemplo h7
o h5 no este h5 Por cierto el h5n1 es el
que está contagiando a tantos animales
hoy en día pero parece por ejemplo que
ahora seguimos resistiendo para terminar
algunos datos como de contextualización
vemos que desde 2003 han habido este
número de contagios tanto del h5n1 como
del h7n9 que son relativamente pocos por
haberlo contado durante 20 años es
importante si sabemos Cuáles escapan de
este bloqueo y cuáles no tendremos más
oportunidades de saber qué virus tenemos
que vigilar desde más cerca y cuáles
Pues nos podemos relajar un poco Claro
que sí mar Bueno pues muchas gracias por
toda esta ampliación de salud nos vemos
mañana nos vemos mañana Valentina